So what is the most important lesson
you took out of being a founder in
your company?
>> Well,
I learned business lessons, right.
There are things I learned about running
a company that I think were valuable.
I've written a bunch about this,
sort of saying don't rely on one
channel to acquire all your customers.
And if you do, know the risks.
When you're young, as a company,
you have to rely on things to
a degree that's probably not healthy.
And you gotta make that trade,
and know where it came from.
Actually, Google did the same thing,
right, Google's Yahoo deal.
When Yahoo was sending them all of their
search traffic, that made the company.
Had Yahoo pulled the contract or
said no, I think Larry and
Sergey would be in a different place.
And maybe, they probably would have
figured it out, because it's them.
But that's a trade you gotta make.
But for me personally, I think I just
learned a lot about what I'm good at,
what I'm bad at, how to manage people.
How to manage co-founders and
work with co-founders
like people who are your equals,
but you have to keep them on track.
Which is very difficult, especially as a
CEO, where they're keeping you on track,
you're keeping them on track.
That's a really tough thing to manage.
>> And from a product point of view,
what is your insights?
>> Know your customer really well.
We built the wrong product at first.
Because we had a conception of our
customer that wasn't accurate, I think,
in terms of how we initially
built our marketplace.
And I think we didn't understand
our customer quite well enough.
And we didn't really solve our
own problem when we started.
And I think we should have.
I think we would have been
a more successful company,
had we hewn closer to our
own really deep problems.
because we lost a lot of
iteration cycles on that.
So if I where to start another company,
if I left and
started a company,
I think it would be something that I
understood more intimately as
someone who experienced that thing.
>> Right, so
why would I want to be a entrepreneur?
>> I don't know that you do.
It's a funny thing, I think that people
give different answers to this question.
Because I think it's actually
different for different people.
I don't think there's one way that you
can look and say, I checked these boxes,
I know I want to be an entrepreneur.
For me,
it was a question of degree of control.
I had worked at companies beforehand,
and
just never felt like I was actually
influencing the success or
failure of those companies, or
the vision of those companies.
And I wasn't happy with that.
I play well with others, but
I'm not great at being managed,
depending on who the manager is.
So that's something that indicates
maybe I should be a founder.
And I wanted to do something really
large, that was kind of out-sized to
the opportunity set offered
by working in a company.
We kind of look at startups as the most
rapid way to impact the largest number
of people in the world.
To think that Facebook went
from nothing in 2005 to having
1.3 billion monthly active users
in ten years, is astonishing.
There's nothing else on Earth that I
think has reached that many people
that quickly.
I think the closest examples
are probably religion, right.
And those take centuries to
hit that many people at that
deep a part of their life.
It's technology that can do that.
Radio and television before that, and
now it's startups on the Internet.
>> So passion has a big part of it.
>> Huge.
I mean,
you have to believe in what you're
doing, or really want to do it.
I think there are people who found
companies not because they're
particularly passionate, but because
they see a really great opportunity for
making money.
And I think that that's always in there
somewhere for people starting companies.
They want to be billionaires or
something like that.
But I think for the most part
the people who really succeed
are the people who aren't doing
it because of the money itself.
There was a great quote or
great thing that I heard when I was on
Wall Street, which is both good and bad.
There's good and bad to this statement.
But a lot of people there say
that money isn't the goal.
It's not how you win the game,
it's how you keep score.
>> Right.
>> Right, and I think that's true for
a lot of people.
They're not actually earning money for
money's sake.
They're earning money because
it's the metric, right?
It's the proxy for
showing that you built something huge,
something huge and valuable.
So I think that if your
drive is to change lots and
lots of people's daily lives,
how they work, or
impact a lot of people, then you should
probably try to start a company.
If you want just more autonomy
in your life, start a company.
It doesn't have to be a startup, right.
It can be a business.
>> Right.
>> Like a small business that gives you
freedom in your life.
That's amazing.
Don't fetishize the idea of startups and
these things that will touch everyone,
if you just want to build
something with your own hands.
I think fundamentally that's
what it comes down to.
>> Very cool, starting a company.